pictures for things and even ideas gave
us proto-writing but we can do better
it's time to invent full-fledged writing
you're ready to grab that chisel and get
your pictographic and ideographic
carving on then someone inventive comes
along your system is artistic but it's
not practical enough for her gone are
the days of Lascaux the world outside
this cave is changing she says crops
cities rulers markets and she needs a
way to keep track of it all she likes
your icons she can use them for goats
and pots fields and even long walks
through the desert but she has an
incredible practical streak she takes
those goats and those pots and starts to
tell you the items she's recording one
goat she says then two goats three goats
four goats notice what she's done these
aren't simple depictions anymore they're
not just ideas she's reading one word
for each symbol she's encoding language
let's slow down here because it's hard
to overstate the importance of this
major moment in the history of writing
these goat counts are word symbols now
logographs pictographs can be visualized
ideographs can be imagined but
logographs can be directly and
consistently read logographic systems
emerge and flourish in the early
civilizations of Mesopotamia Egypt China
and Mexico characters for people animals
land crops hundreds even thousands of
logographs for everything under the Sun
and Moon including the Sun and the moon
even after all these millennia if you
squint hard enough you can still pick
out the symbols scratched into weathered
artifacts bearing the world's early
scripts a Chinese turtle an Egyptian
house a Sumerian head a Sumerian head
eating bread a Mayan Jaguar and in each
of these places in all of these
languages these were read as words we
know what these lower graphs mean and we
can put that meaning into words the
world is now in a race to fill itself
with logographs but which humans started
this Crais well the Mesoamericans
started writing more than twenty nine
hundred years
go some Chinese characters are at least
3200 years old writing popped up in
Crete 4000 years ago but the to clear
contenders are Egyptian hieroglyphs and
Sumerian cuneiform both a whopping five
thousand years old minimum it's common
to say that the Egyptians stole the idea
of writing from Mesopotamia and just
came up with their own glyphs common but
not demonstrated for a while mana
Genesis made sense this is the idea that
one civilization was king of all the
writing that writing started once in
Mesopotamia where people pressed a
stylus into wet clay to make these wedge
cuneus shapes forms cuneiform so the
mana Genesis story goes everyone else
steals cuneiform and Rees skins it to
fit their own needs it's not a popular
story these days given what we know
about Chinese and especially
Mesoamerican writing along with some
very early Egyptian finds whoever's
first in these early days of writing all
the civilizations start manufacturing
hordes of logographs so many in fact
that they unwittingly unleash an epic
memory burden on budding legaud refers
from would-be ancient scribes to
beginning students of Mandarin Chinese
do they really need this many characters
to write surely there's an easier way